la principale difficulté c'est la bouffe
la boule à bout la boule à bout
franchement une appréciation pourquoi j
ai tout sur les 60 derniers kilomètres
moment tu as a chuté ça a été compliqué
de gérer de reprendre ce re motiver pour
repartir
bah ouais bah c'est surtout quand mike
problèmes avec mes lampes la brise un
peu mon moral après ben may blier de
ravitailler - après maints voilà le
temps de revenir elle a été difficile
mamaï un gros coup des difficiles nous
ont tous dû 60e kilomètres jusqu'aux
facilement 80/85 km j'ai l'habitude de
ce genre de compétition notamment la
diagonale des fous
qu'est ce qu'il faut comme particularité
mentales pour aller passer ccc 100 km au
final il faut aller à l'entraînement
franchement moi personnellement me pense
que c'est l'accumulation et les
entraînements fait des kilomètres et des
kilomètres la baie mahault d'être
costaud dans la tête et après bah si
vous avez fait à l'entraînement ou
l'infection compétition messieurs de
revenir parce que l'on puisse me connais
le parcours m'a fait plus plaisir à
mamie parce que l'ama malheureusement
plus question ou cent mille pattes et
atterrit à imiter sans désir monte mais
franchement le progrès les dieux mais il
fait plaisir c'est plaisir